I feel immense responsibility playing
Molly
burkart oil wealth brought a lot of
undesired attention to oage Country this
blanket is a Target on our backs Molly's
family faced latent extortion and murder
to BU them out of their
wealth when the murders start happening
Molly challenges the justice system you
want to go to Washington DC this may be
the last thing I'd
do Molly is really the heroin in a lot
of ways do you have any idea who might
want to harm you Molly he embodies the
pain of the oage people please send help
there's murder in oage and the police do
nothing it's a powerful film and I'm
honor to stand the Theo Sage nation and
the descendants of those who perished I
ought to kill these men who killed my
[Music]
family